i'm more curious your thoughts on how
technology has made us or made certain
people less empathetic and certain
people more empathetic and driven
certain ways
i think the way we're using the word
empathy in politics now
is a little looser than i like to use
the word empathy
it's an action concept it's not
oh tell me your story i want to hear it
i'm so
open to hearing everybody's pain i care
i care i'm not interested in that
that's not going to get us where we need
to go if you're more temperamentally
introverted the fact that you don't go
around saying i care i care i care it's
really better
because that that kumbaya thing
is it doesn't work it doesn't matter
empathy is not just putting yourself in
somebody's place it's putting yourself
in someone's
problem oh i like that
but instead of their place in their
problem there's more solutions oriented
i am in your problem
let's think together what helps you in
your problem
and can i be make a commitment to you
to get into to help you with that
[Music]
problem
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to yang speaks today is a
special episode
today we are talking about the future of
connection with an incredible guest
named sherry turkey sherry has been
writing about the impact on
technology and humanity since before
it was cool so it's her first book on
what technology is doing human beings
uh was written in 1984 before i was born
i don't mean to date you shari you are
uh just a pro though and i think it's so
telling
um when you've been writing about
something before computers had even
become
personalized before the pc existed um to
be writing about how technology can be
making us more alone
and she talks
about how we can't
interact with others and show empathy
and understanding to others unless we
show
empathy and understanding of ourselves
and technology is preventing us from
doing that
and it's a fascinating conversation on
where we go from here as a society as
tech just gets more and more integrated
with
us as humans and her newest book is a
memoir
on understanding empathy for herself and
it's like the culmination of all this
like techy humanistic work
um into a more story form so it's pretty
powerful i learned a ton
by speaking with her um she's a
remarkable woman she's brilliant
i'm confident you guys are gonna learn a
lot too so join me
on this journey on the future of
connection right now
i finally started going to the gym again
feeling pretty good about it and
i just went and i used my new pair of
raycon wireless earbuds
when i went and they were awesome it's
like they're built for me to move around
in which is cool there's no wires or
stems or things like that to get in your
way they come in a range of different
colors
mine's blue which is awesome and they're
built to perform anywhere at any time so
they're water and sweat resistant which
i liked and the bluetooth pairs super
quickly with my phone
so whether you're listening to a podcast
like this one or binging an audio book
or
going through a workout like i'm talking
about raycom is awesome their battery
life's up to six hours
and frankly it's accessible like the
wireless earbuds are starting at half
the price of other premium audio brands
which is cool so right now raycon is
offering 15
off all their products for our listeners
and here's what you got here to get it
go to buy raycon
dot com slash yang that's it you'll get
15 off your entire raycon order
so feel free to grab a pair and a spare
that's 15
off by buy raycon r-a-y-c-o-n
dot com slash yang by raycon.com
yang check them out
[Music]
welcome back to yank speaks everyone i'm
excited we have a special treat today
um because we're going to talk about
something
andrew and myself been very passionate
about for a while and that's our
the future of how technology is going to
impact our humanity
which is a very vague topic in
the abstract when you start talking
about it actually starts getting down to
some very core principles
and one of the best experts out there
that y'all have found and brought to us
on this podcast
is sherry turkle who is the author of a
number of amazing books on this topic
and has just written a memoir
which is like her life's journey in
actually
frankly discovering a lot of what we're
going to talk about today called the
empathy diaries um
and she's a professor professor at mit
and incredibly accomplished um so sherry
welcome to the future of on yang speaks
thank you for being here
i'm so happy to be here i'm so happy to
be here
so there are books written on how
technology is
affecting our humanity there's a lot of
them um not enough frankly in terms of
its
impact on the mainstream but there's a
lot but you've been writing about this
and researching this since way before it
was cool
so tell us a little bit about your
background but i'm really curious on
why you were passionate about this when
no one else
was when everybody like in a certain
time was like tech is gonna be awesome
they're talking about the positive
you're like hey this is destroying us in
some ways like
so tell us about how you got into this
well i fell into it
and when i fell into it i realized i'd
hit gold
i turned i fell into it because i was
given a one-year
um kind of uh post-doctoral internship
at mit i was living in cambridge and mit
was interested i had been studying
psychoanalysis i'm trained as a clinical
psychologist and a sociologist and i was
about to begin psychoanalytic training
and um i'd written a book on the history
of psychoanalysis and mit
uh offered me a position where really i
was
i was supposed to look at artificial
intelligence and cognitive science
and you know think about how they were
going to be hitting the culture much as
you know 50 to 100 years before
psychoanalysis had done the same thing
you know gotten into people's heads
gotten into the popular culture
but when i came to mit was kind of
sitting in my office
eavesdropping on conversations in the
hallways
i heard people talking about computers
as mind machines that were changing the
way they thought about themselves
don't interrupt me i need to clear my
buffer
i need to reprogram myself i need to get
back to source code on my life
i mean it was amazing the way
people were using the computer really to
rethink the self
and um i thought
i'm not going to study the history of
psychoanalysis anymore fascinating
though that was
i'm going to study this i'm going to
study how computers are changing the way
that we think
and i went to the dean you know because
already i knew that mit would be a
perfect place to study this
surrounded by experts in research and
all the things you need yeah hackers and
ai people
and i said you know i i want to stay i
want to be a professor here
um and this is what i want to study and
they said
well if that's a really
dumb idea because the computer is just a
tool
oh no they told you like go like that's
a classic my dad's an engineer
and he's like what are you solving for
um
like that is you know like that is such
a loser
you know what a loser idea
and then i said well look at my you know
i'm an empiricist i'm not a
you know you were talking about people
who study and have ideas and pundits
about
humanity i am the opposite i am a
empiricist i interview people i go to
schools i sit in classrooms i go to
workplaces i go to factories i go to
businesses i i'm listening i'm taping
i'm talking
i said well listen to my tapes listen to
this kid saying
when you program a computer a little
piece of your mind
goes into the computer's mind it comes
into your mind and you see yourself
differently
that's not the computer as a tool that's
the computer is a way to
think about yourself the computer is a
tool you're wasting your time
so i was like okay guys i'm taking my
chances
um i believe that i
have found something you're making me no
promises
i you're hiring me because you think i'm
smart
you think i have good intellectual taste
but
i'm doing this and six years later i had
a book the second self
the computers and the human spirit which
came out in 1984
which really told this story was the
first book that told this story
and this is really before the pc is
extremely popular right like
like the computer's still the size of a
room or whatever it is
um and you're seeing this then you're
seeing people
cranking on the computer and it's
affecting their self then in the early
80s
yes there was the apple ii there was the
trs-80 which you could buy at radio
shack
there was i mean i was seeing the
beginnings of the personal computer
movement
no internet you know and uh so i publish
this book and it gets reviewed on the
front page the new york times and
i'm one of esquire magazine's you know
40 people who were changing
the nation who were under 40 and i get
fired
they fire you yeah they fired me they
came up with some rule but i
i tell this story in my memoir for
whatever you know i
let's say it was a combination of many
factors but
they fired me so i went to the i went to
the provost and i said look
i've written two books i'm super
super good books i'm opening up a new
field of study which is
which is going to be your field of study
i'm going to go to the press and say
what what does a woman have to
do to get a job at mit and i had tenure
the next day
wow good for you good for me but it was
also they really didn't i mean they
they assessed their best interest
because they finally looked at what i
was doing and i think they said
we don't like this i mean i'm very
sympathetic to them
in this memoir i'm very sympathetic to
them because i basically say
you know who wants an in-house critic
it's not so comfortable
having somebody who is telling a very
different version
of the story so i've been a kind of
i don't want to say it in-house critic
but i've been an in-house
alternative voice at mit
really now for decades and um i think
i've brought a lot to the conversation
you've brought so much conversation let
me ask you this has it been frustrating
to you
given how popular tech got and how
intertwined it now is with our
lives and sense of self that this is
something we don't talk about
enough or we talk about in like a little
like oh that's amazing and then we go
back to doing exactly what we were doing
has it shocked you that it hasn't become
as mainstream
um as you and i probably think it should
be no it hasn't shocked me
in the same way that that uh
what we know about sexism what we know
about racism what we know about
uh white supremacy is there anyone who
really didn't know about it
and yet to really confront it challenges
so much about everything the way this
country lives and works and functions
so if you say well uh did you know about
white supremacy
people you know unless people have been
really you know people say well yeah i i
knew i i read those books i mean
yeah i knew well so how surprised are
you by this summer
really surprised this was a turning
point you know
well what made it a turning point is
that people were finally willing to say
yeah this is messed up it goes from a
turning point to a tipping point
to where you are you cannot not speak
and i think that that's really been the
story of my work
in other words i've pointed out you know
for
for 15 20 years i've been talking about
what i call it the golden tran
triangle of democracy privacy and
intimacy
that a facebook messes with your privacy
they're messing with your intimacy
they're messing with your democracy
you can't turn away from that
and yet i've been interviewing people
for 20 years who say
it'll be fine they're making money
people love
facebook whatever excuse xyz we're
changing the world
or or they'll or more likely more likely
the generation that really should take
it on the younger people who should take
it on
as a cause say things that are
so poignant and i i was going to say so
a name but really they're not a name
they're poignant
they say things like i like getting ads
for the stuff i like
in other words they they look at it and
they say i like
i i like all these stuff being free and
i like getting ads for
the things that i want is it really so
bad
in my writing i quote a young woman i
think she was
14 who said who would care
about me and my little life when
when confronted with the fact that her
data was being scraped
and now we know everybody cares about
you in your little life because it's
going to be
bought and sold and put packaged
together with a whole bunch of people
just like you and
sold to estee lauder or whoever the heck
wants to buy it or to bad actors who are
gonna
who are gonna try to try to really
change your voting habits
when you're dealing with something that
has um
such profound such profound implications
politically
as what i've been studying that where
change would be so dramatic
you can't really be surprised if people
don't want to look and don't want to act
you have to just keep at it and i'm
hoping
and i'm optimistic now that the times
will catch up with you
[Music]
so have you ever browsed an incognito
mode i used to use it when i was buying
flights
trying to make sure they weren't jacking
up the prices i kept looking at
something but it is not as incognito
as you think incognito does not mean
invisible and a lot of these browsers
have a form of like privacy mode
and they don't really work that well so
how do you actually make yourself
invisible
express vpn so it turns out that even in
incognito mode your online activity
still gets tracked and data brokers can
still buy and sell your data data
harvesters use your ip to uniquely
identify you and your location with
expressvpn
your connection gets rerouted through an
encrypted server and your ip address
is mass so every time you connect
expressvpn you get a random ip address
it's custom to you
it's only shared within the expressvpn
customer network it makes it harder for
third parties to identify and harvest
your data
and best of all it's super easy to use
even i can use it and i'm kind of tech
illiterate at times so
here's deal if you really want to go
incognito and protect your privacy
secure yourself with a number one rated
vpn visit expressvpn.com
yang and get three extra months for free
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n
dot com slash yang expressvpn.com
[Music]
there's a ted talk you gave um stood the
test of time which a lot of ted talks
don't which i loved about yours um
but i thought it'd be fun to just pull
some quotes
from that and from other things you said
that have
just hit home with me the technology
that brings us together
is actually driving us apart which is
now more of a mainstream
thought i think more people not me more
people are getting that um
and then you said you ratted off some
stats in a number of places where you
thought i think it was 89
of americans admit that they took their
phone out in their last social encounter
that number's probably gone up and then
82
say they felt the conversation was
deteriorated after they did so
i want to hear your perspective how
facebook's supposed to connect all of us
twitter's supposed to connect all of us
text messaging's supposed to connect
iphone's supposed to connect all of us
it is ripping us apart
dive into that what do you mean by that
how do you see that i'm not a luddite at
all
i mean you know i'm people accuse us of
that too
and we're not i have really
a lot of technology and i love it i mean
my god i'm just
you are one of the easiest tech setups
we've had as a podcast guest for what
it's worth you knew exactly what you're
doing
show me a new way to use my technology
and i'm a happy woman it's a
mischaracterization of me to think of me
as a lie
but yeah but and my first book actually
my one of my first books was called life
on the screen was
very um optimistic
about how people could use the fact that
you could play
avatars online to work through
issues of identity that
you perhaps hadn't had a chance to work
through in your regular life
because um i had studied
with a great psychologist and
psychoanalyst named eric erickson
who makes the point that adolescents the
wonderful thing about adolescents is
they're given a psychosocial moratorium
like a time out
when they can experiment with uh
identity
and in in my in my in my memoir i
describe in adolescence in which i was
not given a timeout i was asked to be
perfect
perfect perfect perfect that was those
were the rules
and the idea that you could go online
and experience
with a little bit of you know gender
roles and
uh you know be more
introverted be more extroverted be more
sexually adventurous
i found that fascinating what bothered
me and what i identified as
the first part of your question where i
see the danger is that if you have your
phone out
you are not giving the person you're
with full attention
which means that you are not enabling
an empathic response because empathy
requires
that you know who you are and that you
are coming to someone else ready to give
them your full attention
and that is what concerned me so when
you were kind of going to your computer
doing something on your computer of an
identity sort and closing your computer
down and walking away from your computer
and living the rest of your life
that danger thing didn't go off in my
mind
but when in the middle of a conversation
i said excuse me this i have to look at
my phone
and you're feeling well hold on i've
just made myself vulnerable to you what
about me
what about me then i was concerned
so that was my essential argument about
but by the time i gave that talk in 2012
it was well underway
it's on skis now and i i'm hoping that
the pandemic kind of
slows us down a little bit that is the
real danger
that we undermine our capacity for
empathy
by undermining our capacity for solitude
first of all which is where empathy was
born
in order to be empathic with someone
else you have to be able to sit with
yourself and be
know who you are if every minute you're
being diverted by your phone
you never really need to do that
and so you're not good at it you don't
you look to other people to tell you who
you are
so it makes you a terrible empathic
partner and so that really is where i
was
when i wrote that ted talk and the
reason that it reads like
it happened yesterday there's nothing in
the ted talk that's anachronistic
is that um we're in that same regime
i don't have a lot of natural empathy i
think jonathan hate writes a lot about
like certain people are like more
inclined to be more empathetic like the
bleeding heart
type um i care but like it's and i also
um suffer with um adhd
um it's not i don't have it at a severe
level but um
slightly and that is so that so for
someone that is not that empathetic
like naturally who then maybe struggles
to pay attention naturally as well
you can come off as even less empathetic
and i think people that don't
know me who think i'm you know come off
as either more distant
the people that do know me know that
like if when it's forced in front of my
my face the empathy is there but it's
something i've personally struggled with
and i think
i'm more curious your thoughts on how
technology has made us or made certain
people less empathetic
and certain people more empathetic and
driven certain ways that's a great
question
because it brings the question of
empathy into the into the the
area of politics where of course it
needs to go i think the way we're using
the word empathy in politics now
is a little looser than i like to use
the word empathy
joe biden is empathic is the empathy
president
we all need to be empathic
i'm using empathy in a more um
rigorous way a way that demands
action and political action
i believe it's kind of the most
important political concept
it's a political concept going forward
in this way
it's an action concept it's not
oh tell me your story i want to hear it
i'm so
open to hearing everybody's pain i care
i care i'm not interested in that
that's not going to get us where we need
to go if you're more temperamentally
introverted the fact that you don't go
around saying i care i care i care it's
really better
because that that kumbaya thing
is it doesn't work it doesn't matter
empathy is not just putting yourself in
somebody's place it's putting yourself
in someone's problem
oh i like that but instead of their
place
in their problem it's more solutions
oriented
i am in your problem
let's think together what helps you in
your problem
and can i be make a commitment to you
to get into to help you with that
problem and not only that
um how can i do that and really stick
with it
you know when my students come to see me
and say i don't want to come to office
hours i just want to
send you the right question and you said
i want to send you the perfect question
and i'm going to
you'll send me back the perfect answer i
say no
you have to come see me or now in covid
times you have to spend an hour on the
telephone with me
where i can give you full attention
because i need to put myself in your
problem
because i need to make a commitment to
you so that if you want to go to medical
school
i'm not just writing filling out some
form letter
but i'm really going to go the distance
for you and figure out
what what are your weaknesses so that i
can really
get in there and fight for you it's an
action empathy
it's not just a vague listening empathy
it's a political it's a
and it's it's an empathy with humility a
lot of people's empathy these days start
with
tell me tell me oh you were divorced oh
my god i was divorced i know
i know how you feel the humility to say
i don't know how you feel that's what i
say to my students i don't know your
situation
but i'm i'm smart and i'm a listener
and i'm i i'm i'm secure in my skin
and i'm going to be there for you so the
left loves
we i we tend to take the empathy too far
i say we because i am a democrat i lean
left
um but i think my favorite
older example is um is abolish ice
which um so for example
when in 2000 i think it was 2017 or late
2016 maybe
where we started realizing we had kids
in cages at the border
and the left rightfully so
is like empathetic like oh my gosh
families ripped apart can you imagine
the struggle and like
yes that is horrific we're the united
states of america we should not be doing
this right
and we immediately went to abolish
ice like we eventually how do we solve
this it was like get rid of ice and the
problem with that play is ice
does um a lot of things that are not
related to border security that are
really great like uh
they are our front lines for fighting
child sex trafficking in the united
states and they do a lot of like customs
administration stuff
that we really want and so
the empathetic side i think a lot of
people get put in this bind where like
if you say i don't think you should
abolish ice well you don't have empathy
for the what about the kids in cages
right
um so that and to your point
that is not the pro you're not getting
in to tell me about
solving your problem of empathy like how
do i really understand what our real
challenge is here and we still have the
problem at the border today um so i'm
not saying that we've
you know it doesn't matter who's right
or wrong the problem is we've
then we now have a wedge issue well i
think so many humanitarian
i mean i think that part of the tragedy
of our country today is that so many
humanitarian
problems have become political problems
it's as though if i said to you look
one of the things that concerns me as a
as someone interested in technology and
someone interested in the human
condition
is that i'm not cr i really have the
amount of
writing i have done on why robots
shouldn't be psychotherapists i mean it
sort of fills a book
it sort of fills the book now i have
such good reasons why robots shouldn't
be psychotherapists
mostly because um they don't have human
bodies
it's not that they can't simulate being
asking all the right
questions it won't be smart enough to
ask even more right questions
but since they don't have human bodies
they they are not afraid of death
they're not afraid of losing their
children or in the case of covid saying
goodbye to their children on an ipad
so some of the concerns i've had in the
past year
where i was afraid of death where i
thought i might have to say goodbye to
my daughter
why would i talk how would a robot chat
that would be weird to talk to a robot
about what i was really worried about
because a robot that just would not be
what a robot would naturally
have an experience or an emotional
experience with
so it just seemed obscene that i should
be that i should be thinking about
talking to a robot about these matters
so the point is if that became
a right left issue
we're still at a point where we'd say
well that's stupid
why should you know mitch mcconnell
versus chuck schumer
be taking positions on robots and that's
how i feel about
this thing at the border there it has an
ad about the children in cages
you know what children in cages is a bad
thing but it's a very complicated thing
because they're there for a reason
it's not that the children just show up
how i want to be in a cage
the children the children the children
show up because something is happening
in south and central america
that that that's a a humanitarian an
ecological
political crisis uh that that continues
on no matter who's president and that
needs to be addressed and
and yet it's as though we turned
psychotherapy robots for or against
into something that republicans and
democrats had to take a position on
instead of saying well that's a
humanitarian question and we should
discuss it every
this has nothing to do with politics
this has to do with how we conceive of
the human spirit
it's such a good analogy because that's
not a political fight yet
i'm sure it will be ten years now or
whatever it is
[Music]
all right let's face it guys taking
trips to the post office
is probably not how you want to spend
your time and that's why we recommend
mailing and shipping online at
stamps.com
stamps.comstamps.com
you to mail and ship anytime anywhere
right from your computer send letters
ship packages
and pay a lot less with discounted rates
from usps ups
and more and sams.com has saved
businesses thousands of hours
and tons of money so with stamps.com you
get the services of the post office and
ups
all in one place i love it because i
always forget to either buy stamps or
don't even think about it and i'm like
oh crap what do i do go to stamps.com
bang it's right there super simple easy
you can do it from anywhere you are
because we travel a lot
ship stuff extremely conveniently so
here's the deal stop wasting time going
to the post office and go to stamps.com
instead there's no risk and with our
promo code yang you get a special offer
that includes a four week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale no
long-term commitments or contracts so
just go
to stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the home page
and type in yang that's stamps.com promo
code yangstamps.com never go to the post
office again
[Music]
you have said so many powerful things
you're like this
sage to me in the sense that you've said
things
that not only not only were right at the
time and groundbreaking at the time but
they were
they're more right and more
groundbreaking today ten years later
whenever
you said them so here's a couple you
said we
i'm just gonna read them off and just
let them sit because they're powerful
you've said we expect more from
technology
than we do from each other
you've said we're lonely but
afraid of intimacy you said we expect
we have the illusion of companionship
without the demands of friendship
and that we need to learn to be alone
and these statements are powerful and
they hit you
but i think based on what we're talking
about
a lot of like our political divisiveness
now it's fueled by social media and
there's other things that are fueled by
politics field by a lot of things
but a lot of it is at the core like
we're just not talking to each other and
technology is setting that barrier
what have you seen in your research in
the combination
of more people to talk to but more
lonely
you know um and how that's affecting our
ability to rationalize debate
converse love that sort of thing one
man i interviewed who only one who
basically wanted to do all of his
business
and personal life on on chat
he really likes to avoid face to face
but i i insist on doing all of my
interviews face to face
so i pointed out to him well you know
the conversation we always have
we were having was face-to-face he sort
of took that in but he
he stuck to his guns and he came out
with this he says the scary thing about
conversation
is that it's in real time
and you never know what the other person
is going to say
in other words you are vulnerable
in a way that he hated whereas if you
can hide behind your screen you can sort
of
either drop out say gotta go
or sort of as they're composing you can
kind of compose
a little bit of a false self because
they don't see your reaction
they don't see if you're upset there's
no tone to your statement
what ties together my the ten your five
favorite quotes of mine
is that they're all about being less
vulnerable if you could hide behind
technology the illusion of companionship
without the demands of friendship
is about being less vulnerable because
you can hide behind your screen
have you read um i'm assuming you have
or at least heard of it red igen
yes um it freaked me out and andrew made
me read it before i joined the campaign
to talk about just
what this book talks about and we
actually had the author on the podcast a
while back um
talking about how this tech is in is
hitting our kids
and basically her one of her main thesis
of the book but basically number is that
our kids are developing
slower mentally so like if you're 11
you're
showing the social um
basically actions of a nine-year-old and
you're basically two to three years
behind
um which has oddly some pro a lot of
cons but oddly some pros um at least for
parents in some ways um because they get
to like spend more time with their kids
like their parents more and things like
that which i don't know maybe there's
some benefits there my question is
twofold one just generically what do you
think how is this affecting our children
um and people born in society today like
you know because it's getting
they're now immersed right where it's
babies on ipads what does it do in our
children and
two it's a deeper question does it not
matter in and i know i think i know
where you're gonna stand on this but i'm
curious because
50 years from now uh-huh like 80 years
from now where everybody
100 years from now or anyone who didn't
grow up in the internet age
is long gone is a world but we don't
need human interaction we're all just
like lonely miserable but like
friendship is actually through text and
that's a different way we express
emotion
no no no no no no no
i knew that was the answer but i really
want your thoughts i tell a story in my
memoir i go to a movie with marvin
minsky
who's a great ai pioneer and he was a
good
friend and and uh we had a sort of you
know
working relationship uh but he's really
the greatest ai
person at mit when i get there and we go
to
see tron we come out of the movie and
all the students are standing around and
he was kind of guy who liked to like
give speeches you know about
what he thought and he said what this
movie shows
is that children should see this movie
and they should never see bambi is that
about tron
yeah and i bit i know i went for the
bait i was so stupid i went for the bait
i said every kid loves bambi why can't
kids love bambi
see bambi i want my daughter to see bat
why can't kids see bambi
and he said because much as you've said
now
we're moving towards a society where our
children will be raised by robots
and we're all going to have implants and
we're not going to need
this kind of nurturant attachment
mothering
children shouldn't learn that mothers
are special
children shouldn't learn that death is
special we're not going to die
we're going to be part robot and part
this all the things that bambi teaches
are just sentimental pap
and it's very bad for children to see it
and i remember thinking
as i bought you know extra copies of
bambi for my daughter so we would have
them like every place we went in case
they
pulled bambi i i remember thinking
you know um some of these technologists
and there's this idea that technology is
going to be in our relationships and
technology every
everyone will forget the importance of
just having a conversation and everybody
will forget the importance of
having a mother instead of a more
competent robot to take care of you
i think this is not going to happen i
think that you know
there's that people are going to re
remember
and care about the
the the good old-fashioned values of
human attachment
because they are what makes us human and
i think that
that that is for me the lesson of the
pandemic
is that we have lived as we've been on
our screens as
much as we wanted we've had the best of
tech you get your food delivered you get
your
you want to zoom to london zoom to
tunisia you know
zoom away but basically we have craved
the embrace the full embrace of the
human and i think we've come
to crave it
and and revalue it and
and and realize that there's something
in our
physiology that makes us better when we
have it
and i i think that um
the parents who i interview about you
know going back to school with their
kids
who before before the pandemic
said give me a super computer that will
personalize
learning from my child and give me the
best teachers from all over the world
now they say give me a person
do you have a person to apply to this
child this child needs a relationship
this child needs love this child needs
conversation this child needs
mentors and people who love hugs and
mentors
so i i think this is a learning
opportunity for us to revalue
what technology can give us and to say
but it isn't everything and we really
need people
this is the great hope from the pandemic
in my opinion is that
we learned the extent of how good our
tech is
right now and frankly where i can get
better
it has accelerated all almost every
trend that andrew
yang and and our team ran for president
on
automation of jobs mental health
deterioration
uh income inequality i mean go down the
list however the one silver lining
my hope is like and you kind of had this
in after the spanish flu in the roaring
20s where people are just so
desperate for humans that we
swing the pendulum back the other way
that is my hope
all right if you're like me when you
have a bad night's sleep you remember it
like i can remember
three or four maybe my top 10 even like
worst night
sleeps because it just kills you and
like either up all night or you wake up
with massive backache
and i'm proud to say that i'm a massive
supporter of
helix sleep because they give me great
night sleeps i have the king
lux mattress it's massive it's
comfortable it is
perfect oh i'm a huge huge helix fan so
you go online you take a two minute quiz
you match a mattress with your body type
with your hot sleeper you're like a firm
mattress like soft mattress doesn't
matter you figure out what your
custom preferences are you get matching
the mattress they ship it to you in a
box it pops out beautifully
no hassle super easy it was an overall
mattress top pick
2020 by gq and wired magazine so here's
the deal go to helixsleep.com
yang and take their two minute sleep
quiz and they'll match you to a custom
mattress that'll give you the best sleep
of your life for
real helix is offering right now up to
200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows
for our listeners at helixsleep.com
yanks that's helix h-e-l-i-x sleep.com
yang for up to 200 off and two free
pillows
[Music]
did you see this video came out
yesterday when we recorded it so
recording is on april 9th so this came
out april 8th
uh elon musk uh his company neurolink
posts a video of a monkey tied to his
knurling sensor
uh playing pong with his mind there's a
million
beautiful applications of this and
probably more beautiful than harmful
for sure um but mike and i don't know
no one knows a timeline of this elon
says he's going to start doing on humans
in a year
and so uh you know it's probably five to
ten before it's like
we work out the kinks but then it'll
accelerate um and maybe that's a good
way to start talking about solutions
in talking about solutions i don't think
we've defined the problem
we need to define what we as a country
both individually and for our families
then for our communities
then for the issues we care most about
is it me too
is it is it white supremacism i mean
there's a host of issues
for those problems what technology
what can we look for in technology that
will be genuinely helpful
and then we can say well given that
problem
can technology help me but it isn't as
though
there's kind of like a universe of
everything
and you say elon bring it
bring the monkey and his you know if i
were paraplegic
and i wanted to be thinking about how i
could have
a more natural way of activating
dead uh neurons in my
fingers you know to kind of reactivate
dead neuron i mean i would be
celebrating
in other words there are so many
applications of that but
but to say let's just think about that
and
does that help or does technology help
us technology
technology is not a uh is not a solution
looking for a problem it's much better
when you don't give technology the
agency
and you say you can do some things
can you ha with that technology can you
help me with this
and that's why i think that we have to
be much more the wonderful thing for me
about people with sophistication and
technology coming going into politics
is that people who understand technology
can now say
okay technology i understand you
not like that terrible you know um
scene in congress where people were
interviewing mark zuckerberg and asking
him about pipes and he
i mean it was it was it was obscene
comical comical
people who know about technology can now
turn to technology and say you know
i have some i have some problems with
that real people are suffering with
help me here help me here
um that is where the future should lie
not in not in saying
where will technology take us it's time
to stop that kind of thinking
it's technology i have some places that
i have some places that
income inequality need to go can you
help
i have some places that um
better police training need to go can
you help
i have some pla you know etc etc are
there any
policy solutions either at a local or
federal level that
excite you right now that would start
solving
a lot of the issues you have pointed out
for decades
yeah i mean well a very some one very
basic one i
signed a petition yesterday i think is
that no way i mean
just to show you how low level this can
be but how crucial
facebook wants instagram for children
under 12.
no that is not a good idea i'm just to
show you how granular you can
get when you actually start thinking
about this
like where could technology hurt me
tomorrow
that's a good exercise for everybody to
do instead of thinking oh my god let me
think of some tech policy
where could technology hurt me tomorrow
and hurt the things i care about most
tomorrow i bet there's somebody in the
tech industry planning that very thing
to get people invested in policy you
have to stop
thinking oh policy is like for people in
washington am i no
policy is things that are about you and
your family think of the thing
that really could screw you up tomorrow
what would your recommendation be to
families whether it's parents or just
individuals like myself like hey
tech is like i have like
problems paying attention tech makes
that 10 times worse it
it hurts me um what would you recommend
that people can do now in their daily
lives right to make their own reality
better
i have a simple list the car
dinner the car dinner
food car dinner food no tech
and when you're in the car with children
or with your friends
you say to them conversation is so
precious
talk to me when you're in the car with
your children if you have children
and they they that's when they really
want you to do social media you say you
know
we have so little time to talk i
shouldn't be texting in the car
this is the time i really want to talk
to you
i'm your parent hate me later food
preparation when we're preparing food in
my home
we don't use the phone and then bedroom
i mean the number of couples who are who
are texting while they're in bed getting
ready to be in bed making love
have a notion of sacred space it's not a
religious notion
it's a make up your own idea of sacred
places in the house where they can go
where their phones don't and you could
go there once a day you go
there once every two days i'm not
telling you how much you should go there
but it's some place where you don't
bring your phone and then it gives you
an opportunity
to see what can i think about
when my phone isn't there it gives you
an opportunity to ask yourself that
question i wonder what
ideas come to me when my phone isn't
around but i don't make any rules about
how much television you should watch i
love
television and when i watch television
with my family we talk
we talk to the television we make
comments that's true yeah it can be
really connecting yeah so my girlfriend
um she loves when
we have car time i'm not living in new
york city we don't have a car but in the
pandemic we
would take rent a car and take road
trips um and
she loved it because for me with a like
slight add i have something to focus on
i can focus on and then i can still have
walking's good too but the car um and
you know she's got five hours i can't go
anywhere where you have to have a deep
conversation
um and i enjoy it because i get to know
her better and i get something you know
you get to know yourself better when you
have a good conversation
um so i love that and one thing i love
about your field and your work is
it's been my problem with academics and
look we need academics in general this
research and this stuff is so so so
important but
there's such brilliant research out
there that doesn't get connected to
practice
um and by definition your work has to be
put into practice
because it's literally you're like
studying the practice you're studying
the human
like execution and interaction with
technology um so i love that thank you
uh card dinner food or car food bedroom
however you want to slice that
i'm so curious at this trajectory you've
been on because you've been writing
about tech and humanity
and researching tech community teaching
technology humanity for
you know for years and you then
recently and i'm assuming this was a
covid project and maybe started before
but you became you wrote a memoir it's
called the empathy diaries we
you wrote a completely different book um
about your own personal journey why the
shift why did you go
that way um to to kind of further your
your efforts and vision here the book
began
began when after i wrote my first
book on computers and people which was
called the second self was
1984 and i was holding on to a family
secret
that my the person who i said was my
father was not my father
my mother didn't want anyone to know
that she had been divorced and that i
had a secret father
and she would never talk to me about why
she just said we're never going to talk
about him
and you're going to have to have a
different name and like i i
first i mean i used to go to one school
and i had to write my real name because
it was my
legal name and then i would travel to a
different neighborhood and hide my books
i was the secret agent i was a little
jewish
brooklyn secret agent and um
my interest in empathy began by trying
to figure out why would my mother do
this
the nancy drew of my own life
my i publish this book i get onto the
cover of esquire magazine they come to
write an article
about me and this very nice interviewer
asks me so i just read the second cells
it's like super brilliant you're super
brilliant
you thank your mom who's died you know a
million times
but you don't say anything about your
father so who's your dad what did he do
you know
and i behave i'm like oh i do like a
diva like
oh no i can't discuss that i can only
discuss my work
i i never discuss my personal life no no
i
you know i behave like a super crazy
person like a
super crazy person and he walked out and
of course in esquire magazine he writes
about that i'm a little crazy which was
like
very painful he says something like well
you know her brand is the uh
is the thought and feeling or integrated
but if you ask her a question that asks
about thought and feeling she freaks out
it's so painful to see that stuff in
writing too even though it doesn't fully
matter
it's it matters at the time i just was
like he's right
he's right i've been holding this family
secret for
for four decades what is this you know
what or three decades what is this
so i um i i literally i saw him walk out
the door i knew what was gonna happen
i called up my half sister and brother
i told him the truth i called up milton
turkle
and who was this stepfather who i'd been
lying about i said i'm it's over
you know nothing i haven't done anything
wrong there's nothing so horrible in my
life that i need to hide there
i said i am just free
and then i had to figure out
how this very particular
um background it was clear to me
that this very particular background of
trying to figure out all of these
people's motivations
had sort of set me up in some way
and had i had turned lemon into lemonade
it had
turned me into the kinds of into the
kind of
person who could do the work i was doing
and i wanted to write that book so i've
been writing that this book since really
1984.
you've said this a number of ways in
order to have empathy for others you
have to have empathy for yourself
and understand it did you once you
started having empathy for yourself
did your research and the academic and
the
the hard aspects of the technology and
how we function as humans
did that all just crystallize it was it
was it easier did you see a research
from a different lens there to make you
better
at what you do like how did that impact
it it really did
because i was able to um just function
at a higher level i became more
um everything about me and of course
that there were other things going on in
my life i was in a psychoanalyst
had life experiences i became older i
mean so many things happened it wasn't a
controlled experiment but
i think that really the close
examination of your life and coming to
terms with the
forces that have gotten you to do
the passionate work that you do
make you better at your work uh because
i was able to
approach my work with distance i was
able to
uh um
and a kind of lightness i could see my
stake in it i could be more distant from
it
i was more compassionate with my in
other words you know when
it's like uh as i tell my students
you know uh in work you have ups and
downs some experiments don't work some
books don't work some papers don't get
published some you know
make sure you love the journey and this
book
you know and and my work the better i
understood my work and the better i
understood the importance of my work
uh because there's been many years in
which i've been pitching this story
about computers changing the way we
think and people
just said to me that is the most stupid
thing you know computer's a tool
why are you doing this this is like what
a
this is really not the thing and i just
have to love the work
you know and i have to know how it
connects to my life and i have to know
how
it's really a an expression of my
it's it is my it's my
it's my it's the true expression of my
talents
one of the things andrew and i have been
focused on a lot and i can me personally
like my theory
of change for the next 10 maybe
50 hundred years like i think
authenticity overall is a good schooling
matter
and your book i think points out
that in order to be authentic
you need to really understand yourself
you need to know what that self
is to be confident in your own skin and
it puts the research in a completely
different light and completely more
powerful light
because when people read it um i think
after reading this book and then looking
back at the work that you've done for
decades it's
we know what you stand for you know
where it's coming from you know the
compassion the empathy
that you've had and you're sharing with
others thank you for
writing this your book empathy diaries
guys um we'll put a link to
um where you can get it as well but
sherry it's been
it's been a such a it's an honor just
because how impressive you are but it's
been a privilege just and a joy to chat
with you so thank you for your time
for teaching me some things i feel the
same way it's been really nice thank you
sherry
talk soon everybody
[Music]
you